what makes you a great horror director
what makes me a great horror director i
don't know if i am a great horror
director sorry to put that that label on
you
what i hope makes me a passable horror
director um is the same thing that i
hope would make me a
passable director in general which is
focus on
story focus on character which is so
lame to say because it's such a cliche
but it's just
so true that's that's what makes uh an
experience for the audience and then
the the shock and the horror and the
gore of it all
that's all kind of ornamentation on top
but the the basic structure
still has to be a very solid foundation
in storytelling and that
means to always be very aware where the
audience is
at any given moment in time what is the
information they are processing right
now
what are the emotions that they are
might be fighting
that might be raging inside of them
hopefully if you've done
if you've done your job i think it's
almost like
resource management in terms of the
audience's
energy attention and emotional
involvement i think that's kind of the
backbone of any directing
you know it starts with the writing
obviously that script
has a certain structure to kind of it's
like this rollercoaster
um that the audience is being taken on
and then you are
as the director the person that takes
the blueprints of that roller coaster
by builds the roller coaster and then
finesses the roller coaster always with
the audience kind of
simulated in your head which is really
hard because you've said so long
with the script and with the characters
that you have almost lost
touch with what it's like to experience
it for the first time
and yet you are building it for people
that are experiencing it for the first
time
which to me the whole um which is why
the whole
test viewing process that i know many
filmmakers
despise to me is actually a really
important one
it's depressing and i want to kill
myself every time after a test screening
because you get all these
problems that you didn't even know you
had
and your film had and you felt pretty
good about it and after a test screening
you are sure to feel shitty about your
film
but it's so important because the first
time that an audience that sees it for
the first time tells you their opinion
and if you don't
listen you're kind of lost and that took
me a while
to figure out so i would i i would hope
that what makes me a good director
is how closely i can simulate the
audience experience
in my mind years ago i had gone and
gone to a few of those test screenings
where people would just hand you the
passes you know on the street and they
always made sure that you weren't
in the entertainment industry and i
found that very interesting because
you're going to have a different
perspective
and this was probably like 15 years ago
so
my perspective on storytelling would be
much different than it is
right now right but yeah i remember just
the detail of why they wanted to know
certain things yeah ratings it's always
with these test
screenings what's so interesting to me
is that by the time that you do the test
screening
you've worked on for so long that you're
obsessing over these details
oh there's that one taken there where
she doesn't fully turn
it destroys the movie and then you test
screen the thing
and not only do they not have a problem
with that take
they have a problem with what something
much more basic and much more
fundamental
in the first act which is like oh i
don't think this should be a horror
movie this should be a musical
and you go like what are we talking but
that is how people consume
these things and same for me when a
friend gives me let's say a rough cut
and i give notes on that do i then want
to see
the final movie if i do
i always have the feeling that's the
same as the rough cut of course if i had
sat in the editing room with my friend
doing the notes i would know that this
is a completely different animal from
what i saw two months ago
but as in just as an audience i take in
what the rough story is what the rough
conflicts are
whether i like the characters or not and
i have no
real interest in whether that take is a
little bit
underdeveloped or over exposed or
whatever you know it's the broad rush
strokes
and that is something you have to try to
get back to as a director when you test
screen your movie and that's
really hurtful it really is a dangerous
difficult process to kind of get back
into that mindset
and then flip back out of it and be
detail-oriented again it's kind of a
schizophrenic
process a little bit yeah i wonder how
much
focus groups and things like that
whether it's product testing or whatever
are really that helpful or the fact that
you know you were there to quote pick
something apart
right i wonder i wonder yeah if you
really well my test screening that
is not really that big marketing test
screening it's more like a group of my
friends
that see it for the first time where
know exactly what their tastes are
what they like what they don't like and
if someone
loves let's say this this kind of scene
but has a problem with that scene then i
better listen
to what that person has to say because
there's probably something in which to
me is different from a big marketing
kind of survey where i don't know who
these people are there's still something
valuable in it to hear from the general
audience
kind of a thing but it's much more
valuable to have 10
hand-picked people that you also if you
do
a couple of test screenings different
stages of your film
that you have very much in mind whom to
invite
when who is the most helpful when whom
do i want to hear
from right after the shoot when i just
show them some dailies
is that the most helpful for that person
and how that person gives
feedback or is it more helpful to edit
the movie
polish it and then let that person see
the
cut right before i lock it you know
there are those people and those people
and at some
point after you've done it a couple of
times you kind of know you are
know your feedback people and when to go
to whom
you